how would your objectives here or the
way you view them not be considered
worship when you're like you would even
argue or could say revolves around this
thing
it's not to make money and to live super
comfortably while other people are
suffering and so on and so forth because
they couldn't make it and you could what
if i said that's not your purpose what
if you had a greater purpose in life and
i could tell you what that was would you
then go and seek that purpose gotta hear
this purpose
yeah i gotta hear
all drake okay he's gonna ask you
something though okay all right all
right you guys down yeah all right
what's your name ben nice to meet you my
man
christian adam aidan nice to meet you
all right ben christian and aiden all
right i have a very simple question for
you guys
what's your purpose in life
what is your main objective what do you
wake up and think i'm going to do this
today
make a lot of money make a lot of money
you a lot of money treat people with
respect okay okay i like that i like
that what's up
treat people respect succeed in life
what does success look like to you
living in a nice house nice job nice
family we're in the family one with a
family living with a nice bad stuff okay
okay make money respect people live a
good life support family so on and so
forth i'm loving what i'm hearing so far
would you guys say that you worship this
thing what do you say you worship these
goals you worship these purposes and
objectives i don't worship it but like i
think about it i think about it like
yeah i think about the same i think
about i like try my hardest but okay all
right so the definition of worship right
is having reverence for something and
reverence is having a deep respect for
it or maybe even a yearning for
recognition of it right so now with this
definition how would your objectives
here or the way you view them not be
considered worship when you're like you
would even argue or could say revolves
around this thing
it leaves you a little lost right
so
my next question and this is a really
important one all right so take a second
to think about it where does this
purpose come from did someone come and
say christian this is your purpose in
life go make money and and your mom
comes to you like your purpose is make
money make me happy you know where do
you get your purpose from
just thinking about it because like i
don't know like like coming to niagara
falls you see some people on the street
you're like i don't know if i want to be
like that when i'm older
okay i see so you see some people you're
like i don't want to be like that
so
yeah i know i feel you
100 yeah 100
so
let what if i told you that actually
that's not your purpose in life the
reason you are on this earth right
the ayden christian and ben right
the reason you're on this earth and
you're living this life is not to make
money and to live super comfortably
while other people are suffering and so
on and so forth because they couldn't
make it and you could all right not that
it's a bad thing what if i said that's
not your purpose what if you had a
greater purpose in life and i could tell
you what that was would you then go and
seek that purpose
i got to hear this purpose oh yeah i got
to hear it you got to hear it you got to
hear it okay the purpose of life right
it's not to go for just what you desire
your purpose in life is to serve god now
i know you're thinking oh it's this
again i hear this all the time but think
about it
did success and money and so on and so
did that create you did that put you on
this earth no so who put you on this
earth
amazing so why how come and this isn't
to judge anyone you know everyone's
it has their struggles and stuff but so
why was your answer not to worship and
please god
and be from the successful ones meaning
that god considers me someone who's
successful in life because you were just
telling us like what's our purpose was i
don't know i didn't really think it was
about god or anything but like thinking
about it like i could see it yeah think
about it right yeah and you know what
that's actually not a bad answer i'd say
most people would give that kind of
answer and something one piece of
information that's a little thought
provoking is that goal you have it's not
something you decided it's not you think
you're welcome to decide that you're
wrong what taught you that is the
lifestyle that we're living capitalism
liberalism secularism all these isms
these ideologies that men created years
ago they're the ones who dictated said
this is your objective christian ben
this is your purpose and you your only
meaning in life is to make money
but what does god want for us god
created us
part of me live to the fullest
in what way
i don't know like enjoy everything you
have in life like enjoy everything in
the moment granted pretty much don't
take anything for granted i'll take
anything for granted don't take anything
for granted be grateful be grateful it's
beautiful so i have a gift for you i
wish i had one for each of you you might
have to share i'm gonna turn to a verse
here and i want you all just i'll read
it out to you guys i just want you to
reflect on it and i'll give it to you
guys this is the quran right the prophet
saw mentioned that the bridge between
belief and disbelief is abandoning salah
if you're struggling with your salah
right now well we got the perfect
solution for you and that solution is
the adan app this cell phone we usually
have it and it's using us
instead of us using it
but with the adan app you can use it in
perfect alignment with your life the
adan app is already used by 40 million
believers around the world why because
it caters to your islamic lifestyle on
top of the salah times you get duas
vikkar the islamic calendar ramadan
calendar suhur and iftar times
hajj and umrah guide
and much more for free so download the
addon up now
if i didn't explain this before i'm a
muslim right yeah i'm a muslim i believe
in one god this is what islam teaches
one god worthy of worship who sent the
prophets and messengers like moses like
noah like jesus we believe in jesus
peace blessed be upon him and the
prophet muhammad peace be upon him who
brought this book for us so i'm going to
turn to a verse here which i was
reflecting on today which actually
inspired the question that i asked you
guys let me just pull it up here
the chapter is actually called the
kneeling have you seen the people who
take their desires as their own god
meaning whatever you desire you know
women money fame fortune you make that
your god you worship that thing you
dedicate your life to that thing
i mean
i mean god comes first obviously before
anything so like
whatever i do it's just because of god
and god's just there like that's very
beautiful
that's a beautiful thing that's a
beautiful thing my man so i won't hold
you guys any longer i appreciate the
time i do want to give this to you guys
give it a read reflect on it hopefully
if you guys want to see youtube channel
it's a way of life sq it's the brother
right there you're going to see his
channel and hopefully you'll see your
faces
the halal drake shout out to the hell i
say hello drake hello drake roger
love drake you already know hello jake
yo boys boys boys boys you got some real
ones you got some real for real for real
be safe tonight man don't get into so
much trouble yeah i mean yo god bless
bro be easy
wow wow this guy come here bro wow
subhanallah subhanallah really bro what
a great job what did you feel about that
bro i was honestly i was really proud
alhamdulillah i think they were very
very nice people i hope inshallah allah
guys
what did you do that was just so like
you had a really nice technique so like
this was your first time speaking
someone like this uh street wise tell me
more yeah well i do a lot of debates
alhamdulillah to a lot of different
people the street dawah i've only done
it one other time okay all right so i
learned a bit from that alhamdulillah i
was watching you doing masha'allah and i
was just thinking you know what
something that if i ask people they'll
answer in a way where they're probably
against or away from islam but i can
always bring it back
so that's why i asked about their
purpose
i heard that i heard that idea of the
purpose and i think that that's a great
strategy i'm gonna try and i think that
you guys should be trying at home too
guys we don't want to make this
exclusive just for us like we have some
type of ownership of the tawa this is
everyone's responsibility hit the
streets grab a quran and grab people's
attention because this is the duty of
allah rami you smashed it
they look really interested make the way
for them as well too guys we're gonna be
back we're gonna give out more dollar
guys stay tuned